Florian Philippot,
les patriotes
mettent en avant 1
programme qui souligne l'importance de la souveraineté
nationale et propose des mesures
spécifiques pour la France et l'Europe,
appel à 1 sortie de l'Union européenne ou frexite
afin de restaurer la pleine souveraineté de la France,
insistance sur la nécessité de renforcer le
contrôle aux frontières
pour gérer l'immigration et assurer la
sécurité nationale,
proposition d'une politique économique
protectionniste visant à soutenir les entreprises
françaises et à préserver l'emploi en France,
critique des accords commerciaux européens actuels
avec 1 volonté de les renégocier
pour protéger les intérêts nationaux,
engagement envers La Défense de l'identité culturelle
française et européenne
tout en mettant en avant la liberté d'expression
et les valeurs républicaines.
Le parti l'épatriote de Florian Philippot
propose 1 changement
radical dans la gestion de l'Union européenne
en privilégiant les
intérêts et la souveraineté de la France.